no just take a look at that clock
ticking down at the top of the screen
the government's promise to get brexit
done will be delivered at least in part
at 11 o'clock on Friday night when the
UK officially leaves the European Union
but whispered it quietly not much will
change because there is that transition
period that lasts until the end of
December and of course more talks on
trade and our future relationship you
could say that the business of actually
getting brexit done is only just
starting well let's get a view from the
other side of the negotiating table
Ireland's Europe Minister Helen McEntee
joins us now from County Minister thank
you so much for for being with us this
morning and what is your view of whether
or not over the next 12 months we can
get a deal done well as you've said I
think my own view and my own party's
view is that brexit is really only at
half time we have a huge amount of work
still to do I think it's very welcome
and I say this with a tinge of sadness
is very welcome that the withdrawal
agreement has passed through all the
stages in Westminster we know now that
the European Parliament is recommending
that it pass through and yes on the 1st
of February the UK will leave and
nothing will change however the idea
that we can negotiate a trade deal one
that is close comprehensive one thus
provides very little change for our
citizens not just in the UK and Ireland
but the EU as well within about a 12
month space it's very difficult now of
course the EU is willing and ready
Michel Barnier is still our chief
negotiator he is working with his team
and all Member States Ireland included
to ensure that we have a mandate and
that we are ready for these negotiations
when they start but we do know of course
thus Boris Johnson has said he does not
want to have an extension which means
trying to negotiate a very difficult
trade deal essentially in 10 months and
we know looking at previous trade deals
how long they have taken but of course
as I've said we are willing we are ready
but we do need to make sure that in all
of the negotiations
Ireland's priorities are heard that the
other 26 Member States priorities are
heard and that there is a level playing
field that we have a
of rights and obligations throughout all
of this I'm Boris Johnson said on this
program of the or of the agreement
struck an agreement which many people in
fact didn't think was possible that it
allows the whole of the UK to come out
of the EU including Northern Ireland and
the only checks that there would be
would be if there was something coming
from gbv or Northern Ireland and was
going on to the Republic then there
might be checks at the border into
Northern Ireland that that's not
entirely true is it can you envisage a
border without checks well what we know
is the withdrawal agreement that has
been negotiated the most recent updated
version is very clear there will be no
checks on the island of Ireland we've
been very clear on this we need to
protect the Good Friday Agreement and
integral to us has been the invisible
border which has existed since the Good
Friday was a put in place over 20 years
ago
it protects the all Island economy which
has become again part of that
cooperation and the involvement among
our communities north and south on this
island with the withdrawal agreements
and the technicalities of exactly how
that work this will be discussed and
this will be put in place throughout the
transition period and but we do know
that there will be some checks coming
from Great Britain into Northern Ireland
and that is to ensure the protection of
the single market that's to ensure that
any Goods that are coming into Northern
Ireland and then into Ireland and
perhaps through the s through the rest
of Europe and into the single Marcus and
that they are the integrity of those
Goods are upheld of course if we have a
free trade agreement if we have one that
is so close that we do not need checks
or buy that there are no changes and
whether it be tariffs or otherwise then
that obviously changes things however if
we come to the end of this year if there
is no trade agreement in place then of
course the Irish Protocol will come into
place and all of the things that I've
just outlined protecting the border
protecting the oil island economy
protecting the common travel area and of
course the peace process they would be
very much at the heart of the Irish
protocol which will come into play and
by the end of the year but again this is
only if a free trade agreement is not
negotiated our focus on our priority and
it shouldn't just be about timing this
idea that we need to get something done
by
the end of the year for us it's about
pushing the right negotiation the right
relationship and place like laying those
foundations and making sure and that we
have a trade relationship not just a
benefit sauce but that benefits the UK
because we want to continue to have that
close relationship indeed just a little
earlier on in the program however I mean
I put a question about divergence to the
Home Secretary pretty Patel and she made
it pretty clear that whole point of this
was to permit divergence I mean in those
circumstances if you are in still
imposed wood island veto any deal that
permitted the level of divergence that
Miss Patel was talking about what this
isn't about Ireland vetoing any deal or
any member state receiving a deal I
think we're all in agreement all 27
member states that we want a close
relationship with the UK but there has
to be as I've said earlier a balance of
rights and obligations there needs to be
a level playing field we need to protect
not just the single markers but we need
to protect the rights and the values
that underpin our membership of the
European Union you know I think it is
quite worrying that there's a lot of
talk about divergence but this is why
for us and particularly in Ireland the
withdrawal agreement was so important
this is why the protocol specifically on
Northern Ireland was so important
without a trade deal which essentially
deems it not necessary we need to ensure
that no border can ever be reconstructed
on this islands that the old Island
economy which has evolved in so many
ways and everything from agriculture to
our electricity Marcus to education to
health that body is protected but most
importantly the peace process where we
have seen communities evolve begin to
work together where we have seen peace
for over 20 years that that is not
impacted and any kind of divergence in
regulations without that protocol would
mean a return to those kind of issues in
the past and that is why it's so
important as I say at the beginning
again it's it's it's not something that
I want to see happen the UK leaving but
for us what's so important is that you
leave with a withdrawal agreement in an
orderly fashion and of course I focus
now on our priority is to work with you
as quickly as possible to try and ago
she had a trade deal but again this
should not be about timing this should
be about getting
right there I mean you mentioned a
moment ago the kind of the all-ireland
economy excuse me as of one minute past
11:00 on the 31st of it toolbar in your
mind what are the prospects moving
forward for a unified Island for a
united Ireland well we have always said
I have said in my government and I think
most political parties in Ireland are
very clear that now is not the right
time to broach that subject yes I think
the question itself has obviously become
much more it has come much more to the
fore in recent years however our focus
and in particular this government's
focus and our priority has not been just
to get through as you say and to manage
an orderly greg's us for us we are only
as half-time there is a huge amount of
negotiation and a huge amount of effort
that is needed now to make sure that we
get a good deal and from again our
government's point of view our economy
the prospects for our economy were very
much depend on whether or not we have a
good relationship with the UK the EU is
still our largest trading partner but
from any business in particular small
and medium enterprise the issue of north
and south has been protected however our
trade east and west between Ireland and
the UK that is an extremely important
relationship and one meeting and I hear
you and I hear you on and I hear your
note point is around these negotiations
not fast but if there were to be a
ballot on a united Ireland would you
vote yes again this is not something
that I think we should be discussing now
because I think what it does is create a
further divide we've seen how in
Northern Ireland it's taken three years
to bring our executive back and our
focus needs to be of making sure that
our parties in the north are working
well together that we are upholding all
of the provisions of the Good Friday
Agreement and that we're looking towards
this next stage of the negotiations as
I've said were only as half-time and I
think now to start talking about any
kind of a border poll or any kind of a
referendum or that kind of a position
would only actually be negative so I
think our focus needs to be on the next
stage of the negotiations there's a huge
amount of work to do the idea that we
would negotiate a trade deal in 10
months
it's a it's a huge challenge and for
some I think it's an impossible
challenge but something that we are
willing and ready to do and our focus
needs to be on this absolutely a to
torture of the analogy briefly just for
a second we may well be at half time in
terms of the negotiations I'd like to
look forward to to next season
do you see a the United Kingdom
returning to the EU at any point well
you know I think all member states and I
think most people in the EU would
welcome the UK back tomorrow if that
were the case boss I don't think that is
the case and I think we need to to start
focusing on what happens next the first
of February is not too far away in fact
it's just a matter of weeks and our
priority needs to be on what kind of a
relationship we will have with the UK we
need to ensure the close relationship
Ireland and the UK have had yes I think
along and at times tumultuous
relationship but we are close neighbours
we are close friends and allies in many
ways as is the EU and I think a priority
needs to be on what kind of a future
relationship we can have how we can work
together not just in economic terms but
around security and as I've said
protecting so many of those rights and
that underpin and so many of those
values that underpin the European Union
human rights freedom of expression
equality of all for all persons so we
need to work together on mass administer
whilst we have you we learned of the
death of a Seamus Malan course deputy
leader of the SDL people the Good Friday
Agreement was signed Deputy First
Minister in the assembly and your
thoughts on his life and legacy well I I
think his legacy is here for many people
to see I think he played such a
significant and important role in
bringing about the Good Friday Agreement
but in bringing people together in
communities together and I think the
fact that the Good Friday Agreement
albeit we've had challenges in recent
years I think it's only growing stronger
and I think his vision for Northern
Ireland his vision for Ireland and our
relationships and communities in the
north is one that will live on for a
long time and I
are from my deepest condolences to his
family to his friends I think his legacy
below live on for a long long time
Helen McEntee many thanks for joining us
thank you